-Performing "Moneymaker"
from their new album, "Let Yourself Free,"
please welcome Fitz and the Tantrums!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ Shake your money, shake your money, shake your moneymaker ♪
♪ Shake your money, shake your money, shake your moneymaker ♪
♪ Oh, me, oh, my, my ♪
♪ You getting yours, baby, I get mine ♪
♪ Little crazy is what I like ♪
♪ Never seen a party that's a waste of time ♪
-♪ Ooh-ooh-ooh ♪
-♪ We running running, yeah, we're running the show ♪
♪ We started something, yeah, we're ready to go ♪
-♪ Hit the lights, shut it down ♪
♪ Get lost in the crowd ♪
♪ Lose your mind, set it free ♪
-♪ If it feels good, feel it, yeah, follow my lead ♪
-♪ Shake your money, shake your money, shake your moneymaker ♪
♪ Shake your money, shake your money, shake your moneymaker ♪
♪ Do it how you do it, go and get your paper ♪
♪ We're running, running, now we're running the show ♪
♪ We started something and we're ready to go ♪
♪ We're spinning around 'til it's out of control ♪
♪ We're going wild and we ain't going home ♪
♪ To the left ♪ -♪ If you're blessed ♪
-♪ To the right ♪ -♪ Alright ♪
-♪ Shake it up ♪ -♪ Shake it fast ♪
♪ Now you're in the spotlight ♪
♪ Ooh, whoa, me, oh, my, my ♪
♪ You've been getting yours, I'll be getting mine, so ♪
♪ Shake your money, shake your money, shake your moneymaker ♪
♪ Do it how you do it, go and get your paper ♪
♪♪
♪ Hit the lights, shut it down ♪
♪ Get lost in the crowd ♪
♪ Lose your mind, set it free ♪
♪ If it feels good, feel it, yeah follow my lead ♪
♪ Shake your money, shake your money, shake your moneymaker ♪
♪ Do it how you do it, go and get your paper ♪
♪ Shake your money, shake your money, shake your ♪
♪ Oh, oh ♪
♪♪
♪ Shake your moneymaker ♪
[ Cheers and applause ] -Come on! That's how you do it!